junges kocsis am start es cox in der
stadt zwei kopf ab
servus es geht zum herzlich willkommen
zu einer neuen folge genau mit genau
mensch ihr radikales das gibt's ja nicht
nein ich bin heute zum ersten mal
get down auf den zeitpunkt des ersten
mal damals zum ersten mal eine aufnahme
zum ersten mal eine aufnahme und carney
ist im am start
für moralische unterstützung der
gauleiter wie in diesem können bürger
vorbei doch der spielmodus künftig so
entsteht einfach ne moment man muss
möglich sein nach unten kommen
ich sitze da rechts ich bin eh nix
gerade auf platz 2 max ist royal smg
gerade auch im hinteren platz das wurde
gerade hoch gesetzt von dem konsum wurf
blog das hat mich gefreut
ja und irgendwie max ist audioqualität
gewissen komisch weil planung immer noch
ja du bist ein bisschen aber es geht
eigentlich als der teamspeak spinnt also
es sollte eigentlich so sein
ich behaupte jetzt einfach das mag man
nicht gering aber es liegt nicht im
teamspeak bei mir auch schon mal gut
dann liegt es an dir dann ist irgendwas
ranking aber auf jeden fall wo gott
jetzt bei strange das einspielen
okay wir haben 14 blöcke bis zum boden
in 14 block drop ist eigentlich keiner
den ich jetzt unbedingt so direkt machen
will aber den hier mache ich und first
place sehr schön
na gut aber okay erste runde gewonnen
drei punkte gerettet 201 es gibt drei
runden davon indem man runterfällt
idealerweise nicht verhält sondern
runtergeht kontrolliert und erhalt
gesammelt unter anderem konnten als
erster an komplex ich noch mal ein korn
booz & tracing points kann am ende was
kaufen so wahrscheinlich welt ihr schon
kennen weil der modus jetzt nicht so
nagl neues die sätze von mir nicht mehr
scheitern machten und dann halt mich mit
der bz ich unterhalte dich so gut ich
kann
ich habe schon ein
ich hoffe ich habe ich schon einige
steine aufgaben bekommen diese bisher
ich sehe auch keinen man die band gerade
richtig vorenthalten diese teile irgend
jemand sitzt dabei gewässer punkt tvm
ich glaube einfach unter die einfach vor
deinen augen alle weg ist glaube ich
nicht alle
ich glaube moderner und mein erster
corner blockt er mich einige leben
gekostet
was macht dieser nebel stellt hier ein
bisschen aber da kommen jetzt nicht hin
nach dinge aber wir sind wieder auf
platz eins heißt wir können wieder schön
finde schon finnischen bringt ihr auch
nicht so viel
jedoch finde schon bringt mal so viel
wie zwei blöcke 110 und halte same auf
der straße des vergessens schnitt auch
deswegen hast du durchaus das ist
angedacht
leider nicht mit dem herzen ist schon
wieder alles lief so bones damit zweimal
finde ich es nenne ich weiß nicht was
mit 1 120 konz nur 160 weiß nicht ob es
daran liegt dass du das zweite mal
gekündigt hat oder ich glaube schon
alles andere erfolge mein okay jetzt
erstmal resistenz welches nutzen wir ein
paar waghalsige sprünge zu machen
durch das man nicht immer oft ging es
geht wie man so machen dass das man
nicht immer auf finnischen spielt ja
genau
trotzdem gibt es immer machen vielleicht
müsste es auch im nebeneffekt ja und
dann kann auch sein wenn man richtig
drauf hat findet man hat wahrscheinlich
keiner können arbeitet auf einem herz
muss mal kurz zu stellen hoffentlich
keine runter auch hier 14 blick auf den
nächsten
nichts ist hier leute ich bin nichts
riskieren es geht schnell vorbei glaube
ich habe eine extrem gute runde gerade
also insgesamt nur mäßig mann
ok klingt unrealistisch
ich krieg irgendwie immer nur so
dominique 50 immer auch wenn ich relativ
viele ein sammler hat vielleicht einen
schlechten ruf und schufa ja weil ich
keine kredite kriegen auch zu keinem
konkreten ich bin nicht kreditwürdig das
hat eines gezeigt
ich hatte so ein bisschen rum dass nicht
zu viele leben ein herz braucht auf
jeden fall ist auf jeden fall jugendwort
wenn es nicht anerkennt trinkt ein bier
oder und jetzt ran deutschen das will
ich nicht okay gut besser messen und so
junge alter gut besser messer des kunden
einfach der spruch für unser shipping
sein wenn wir uns zum essen oder
christin man kann ich auch besten lieber
auf was du tag weil ich sonst kriegst
hey hey meine oma christel mit meiner
oma namens crystal pass auf dass ich
jetzt nicht christ str nachricht du
apostel
der mann darf er übrigens erst dinge
kaufen diese aufnahme wenn man das
joggen angeschafft hat haus gekauft
herzlichen glückwunsch
sie dürfen ihn kaufen ok erstmal
natürlich full die software
durchgelaufen ihr fragt euch welches
matches ich mag ihr behinderten pixar
bekannte materie respekt was mit zellen
abonnenten und zuschauer mit meinen zu
reden
ok alter einen klops heißt der arme
einfach schwer geschädigt tinox ist auch
noch drin junge wie viel das schon
wieder am team sind junge es kocsis am
start oder alternative alter ist man
jetzt stört doch einfach bloß nun
wirklich die alter wie geil ich sag
immer stück einfach stück in genau
diesem moment ich bin da obwohl dir doch
ein fahrrad wenn du willst komm gib mir
ein oder gar zwei oder gar drei dass ich
mir einerlei einerlei aber nicht
einzelne leider scheint sonst ja der fms
beim halter ja komm mir egal jetzt
frisst aber nein nein geht auch junge
gitter und was man erlebt er da man aber
schöne großformat ja zwar gut essen es
drei herzen ist halt bitter hat auch
nicht so schlecht gemacht mit dem haus
über man wie bitte aber hey leute ist
eine spitzenrunde nur niemals gehackt
macht des fahrzeugs aus ich wollte gar
eine bananenschale in die kamera halten
aber dass mich dran